Ucrania planeta está más cerca del otan
que en antes
los aliados reafirman que Ucrania se va
a convertir un miembro de la otan están
de acuerdo en remover los requerimientos
para un plan de acción para la membresía
Esto va a cambiar la vía para membresía
de Ucrania de un proceso de dos pasos a
un proceso de un solo paso para enviarle
la invitación a Ucrania para unirse a la
otan cuando los aliados de acuerdo que
se cumple con las condiciones esto envía
un mensaje claro unificado y fuerte
desde nuestra cumbre en Vila tenemos que
asegurarnos que cuando termine esta
guerra haya arreglos creíbles
establecidos para la seguridad de
Ucrania para que la historia no se
repita
agradezco que muchos aliados se han
comprometido a proporcionar asistencia
de seguridad a largo plazo a Ucrania
Esto va a ayudar a disuadir cualquier
futura agresión de Rusia cuando termine
la guerra
esta mañana
nos reunimos con Los líderes de
Australia Japón Nueva Zelanda y Corea
del Sur así como la Unión Europea
la otan es una alianza regional
pero enfrentamos retos globales
lo que pasa en Europa
no importa la región del mundo Pacífico
lo que pasan lo Pacífico le importa
América del Norte y a Europa
las actitudes de Beijing a nivel mundial
y la guerra de Moscú contra Ucrania
requiere una conexión cercana entre la
otan la Unión Europea y nuestros socios
de la región pacífica
dos programas nucleares y de Corea del
Norte incluyendo su último nacimiento de
misiles
seguridad y representa una amenazada una
amenaza la seguridad mundial la otan
está reforzando sus lazos con Australia
Japón Nueva Zelanda y Corea del Sur con
programas de asociaciones incluyendo
trabajo conjunto en temas tales como el
ciber marítima nuevas tecnologías
ciberseguridad cambio climático y
resiliencia vamos a trabajar aún más de
cerca
y vamos a tomar una postura más fuerte
en el orden nacional
enfrentamos la situación de subir más
seria en décadas pero los aliados están
listos para enfrentar este reto la otan
está más unida que nunca tiene una
postura fuerte en defensa de nuestras
personas en nuestros valores me gustaría
cerrar agradecerle al al presidente
nauceda y el gobierno lituania por esta
Cumbre histórica espero Gracias a la
próxima Cumbre el próximo año que marca
el quinto
aniversario de nuestra Alianza y con
esto voy a decir cualquier pregunta
Gracias